we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
question about Scandinavian countries
and the minimum wage take a listen to
this hello David
I have a question a lot of progressives
say Scandinavian countries are very
progressive so most Scandinavian
countries don't have a minimum wage and
don't have an inheritance tax that being
said I know Scandinavia is more
progressive than America but my question
is do you think progressives in America
exaggerate how progressive how
Scandinavian countries are or do you
disagree with that
no it's incoherent but and if I sounded
bad I apologize I'm kind of like a
first-time caller all right ok so listen
there's a few different issues here
number one yes it won't surprise you to
hear that people constantly miss state
what it actually is like in Scandinavia
the minimum wage thing you have to
understand that in Scandinavia labor
unions are exponentially stronger than
in the United States and they are
maintaining reasonable wages such that a
minimum wage is not even necessary now
conservatives will hear that and they'll
say well it's also not necessary in the
US then the market will just decide no
that's not what I'm talking about
labor unions are involved in collective
bargaining for employees
thus they don't need the minimum wage
it's actually an indication of how
progressive they are that there are
other structures namely labor unions
that are keeping that those wages up
beyond that as far as the Mis statement
of exactly how progressive Scandinavia
is I mean yeah you're going to find
people that will miss state for to one
side or the other how these countries
work you see the left maybe sometimes
miss state how progressive Scandinavian
countries are you see the right argue
that there's nothing progressive at all
that they are merely market economies
and of course the truth is neither the
truth is you have to look in a nuanced
and specific way and say well
what what is going on in Sweden what is
going on in Norway how do these
countries differ and also importantly
how it is the broader context different
from that in the United States such that
our analysis needs to be different
structurally to really understand what's
going on we have a great bonus show for
you today many many stories I'm out of
time in terms of telling you what they
are but believe me they are good and you
can access the bonus show by becoming a
member at WWJ in pac-man comm or a
patron at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show